I think a lot of it it's just with
sports in general you know the UFC takes
a lot of heat for it when guys get done
they're like oh what are they supposed
to do now you know they didn't make
enough money to ride off in the sunset
hate to tell you most sports don't
unless those guys are smart with their
money everyone has to kind of try to
figure out what's the next chapter after
whether you know not compared to the
military because Memorial day but even
the military those guys get done they
have a special set of skills that
doesn't really transition into the real
world now some do you know a lot of them
do but you know you look at the jockos
and some of those other guys Tim
Kennedys of the world that came from the
military background and they're massive
now in fighting you know those guys and
obviously your your personality your
smart guy and then also both you guys
you know before you came on Matt I was
talking about
it's not how well you can do it it's
about how long you can do it well and
you guys at uh you know Ray long on
Sears the camp out there you guys have
been doing it long and pretty damn good
for longer than anybody I know